let's start with index.html don't worry
HTML is pretty simple it describes the
content and layout of elements on a
webpage we'll be comparing what we see
here to the website in this top section
we see the pages head tag defined will
often find CSS and JavaScript links like
these here inside the body of the text
we can see that we've got content that
says hello world and when we flip over
to Chrome there it is if you want to
learn more about HTML check out the link
in the instructors notes looking through
the HTML for our resume there are a few
elements worth noting like this one div
ID equals main I can see that it says
hello world here which showed up on the
website divs represent different
elements on the page you can think of
them as starting like empty all-purpose
boxes in this case we've given this div
a unique ID of main which our JavaScript
we'll be referencing later do you see
anything else James it doesn't look like
a resume at all right now but I do see
some structure for one it looks like
there are sections for education work
and projects what do you think about
filling these in with our resume data
yeah you know what developers have
options for building great web pages and
I think there are two obvious strategies
they can either hard-code the
information by writing HTML that
explicitly defines the content users
should see or they can use an HTML
template and fill it in with data
programmatically when a user requests a
page in this case we can see the two
work experience sections and the hard
coded version we can see all of Philip J
fry data listed here while on the
template side we see the work experience
section but right now it's empty the
hard coded route is good to start but it
isn't a solution for the long term any
time we want to make a change to the
page we have to open up the HTML make
the changes by hand which can be a big
pain for the resume project we'll be
using the template strategy what do you
think that works
me besides if we weren't then this class
would be about HTML which it isn't
yeah there are other great introductions
to HTML online see the instructors notes
for a few links at the top of the HTML
there's a link to jQuery is the jQuery
library there is also helper j/s which
contains some simple helper javascript
we've prepared for your project we'll be
coming back to it in a few minutes we've
got two more script tags at the bottom
of the HTML this tag for resume builder
j-s tells the browser to download and
execute some JavaScript we'll be using
this script to add HTML content to the
main section of the HTML the browser
will render this page just singing hello
world to give you a better overview of
what's going on here
we've zoomed out the page so you can see
everything all at once we have hello
world here some empty resume sections
and then some JavaScript over on this
side we can see a general representation
of how it would look in a browser we're
printing the hello world and then after
the hello world we have all of the
resume sections when we hit the
JavaScript section that includes a
resume builder down here the browser
will run a script which will change the
HTML in these experience sections and
the page will now show our resume but
wait you may ask yourself what about all
of these experience sections it looks
like they're in the resume but they
aren't showing up on the page right now
that's because of these scripts at the
bottom of our resume using javascript
we're checking to see if any of these
sections contain any content and if not
we hide them we'll get a chance to break
down these JavaScript sections later